[Musique]
il ya environ un an et demi je prenais
une décision professionnelle inattendu
inattendu et qui elle est totalement
chamboulée ma vie en effet il y a un an
et demi je prenais une décision qui
était inspiré motivé animé par cette
question
quelle vision nouvelle nous permettra au
21ème siècle de franchir une étape
supplémentaire dans le progrès de
l'humanité vers sa prospérité pour
l'établissement de la paix mondiale
alors à cette époque là j'étais j'ai
exercé la profession d'avocate inscrits
au barreau de paris
et puis déjà depuis près de 20 ans
j'étais en plus bénévole sur mon temps
libre dans une association qui s'est
donnée pour mission d'accompagner les
processus qui permettront
l'établissement de la paix mondiale
cette association l'institut rwi ouvre
oeuvre à travers le monde avec des
activités auprès des enfants des prêts
jeunes des jeunes et des adultes pour
les accompagner les responsabiliser pour
que l'on prenne conscience que l'on peut
être des acteurs du changement
et un soir du mois de mai il ya un an et
demi lorsque nous venions de terminer
les dossiers en cours
la directrice d'une des structures
administratives me propose m'informe en
fait qu'il doit prendre d'autres
responsabilités et que les membres du
conseil
on pensait menou mais pour prendre le
relais alors passer l'étape de la
surprise et du choc de cette nouvelle je
devais prendre une décision pour suivre
dans ma carrière professionnelle dans
laquelle je m'épanouis sait où me
consacrer entièrement
et me dévoue totalement pendant un
certain nombre d'années à cette cause
qui finalement si j'écoute autour de moi
est utopique illusoire idéaliste est ce
que réellement on peut changer les
choses est ce que réellement on peut
établir la paix mondiale et j'avais
cette conviction que la paix est
aujourd'hui non seulement possible mais
qu'elle est
évitables notamment ce je me dis si on
regarde le cours de l'histoire
l'histoire de l'humanité est marquée
d'étape de jalon que nous avons franchi
d'étape qui ont permis à chacune d'elles
de permettre un progrès de l'humanité
ces étapes sont parfois des découvertes
scientifiques des innovations parfois
également elles sont la conséquence de
crise mais chacune de ces étapes à
modifier notre mode de pensée notre mode
d'action
notre relation nos interactions les uns
avec les autres et nos aspirations
prenons par exemple la question
migratoire et les déplacements
comment est-ce que ces événements nous
ont permis de prendre conscience de la
richesse que composent la diversité que
composaient l'humanité prenons les
questions environnementales la crise
environnementale mais également les
avancées technologiques nous permettent
aujourd'hui de réfléchir et de chercher
des alternatives pour protéger
l'environnement de même que la
mondialisation aujourd'hui qui est
présent dans tous les aspects de notre
vie notre vie économique notre vie
privée notre vie sociale et il ya encore
quelques temps la mondialisation était
totalement impossible à imaginer la
société était formé de clan de tribus de
famille donc toutes ces évolutions nous
permettent aujourd'hui de nous dire que
la paix est non seulement possible mais
qu'elle est inévitable alors évidemment
la paix ne se ne peut pas être juste un
mot une théorie un proverbe ivoirien dit
la paix n'est pas un vain mot c'est un
comportement alors en effet si on veut
vivre dans une société juste et prospère
nous devons en être les acteurs si nous
voulons une société pacifiée réunifiée
est ce que ce n'est pas à nous de nous
changer mais également de permettre un
changement de la société
finalement l'apprentissage acquis au
cours de toutes ces années dans cette
association ont permis de prendre
conscience que nous sommes les
bénéficiaires de la société mais nous en
sommes aussi les initiateurs de cette
société dans laquelle on vit que nous
sommes responsables de la société dans
laquelle nous sommes dans laquelle nous
vivons
mais également de la société que nous
allons léguer
alors quelles sont ces comportements
quelles sont les étapes à franchir pour
pouvoir aller vers cette paix car il est
évident que nous ne pouvons pas rester
au stade de la théorie mais qu'il faut
agir comment ce qu'on a réussi à mettre
en évidence c'est qu'il y a des jalons
encore à atteindre avant de pouvoir
atteindre cette paix mondiale de jalons
peuvent être mises en évidence
l'unité du genre humain une première
étape et donc de prendre conscience que
nous formons une seule et même entité
une seule et même famille la famille
humaine et non nouveau seuil et de
d'établir cette unité du genre humain
un deuxième jalon est celui de la
prospérité prospérité matérielle aisée
mais également prospérité spirituel et
chacun de ses jalons appelle une vision
nouvelle
une vision nouvelle de ce concept mais
aussi une vision nouvelle de notre rôle
du rôle que nous pouvons jouer pour
atteindre ce jalon ses jalons qui vont
nous permettre ensuite d'atteindre la
paix mondiale alors quelle vision
nouvelle pourrions-nous avoir de l'unité
du genre humain
nous sommes comme je disais aujourd'hui
conscient que l'humanité est constitué
d'une grande diversité diversité
culturelle diversité linguistique
diversité religieuse diversité sexuelle
et c'est cette diversité qui fait la
richesse de ce monde dans lequel nous
vivons
mais comment vivre dans cette diversité
comment gérer les interactions dans ce
monde si diverses
alors il est je pense qu'on sera
d'accord avec moi évident que le conflit
et l'opposition ne peuvent pas être la
règle sociale de notre humanité
alors comment pourrions-nous créer de
l'unité au sein de tant de membres
divers dans une même famille
j'aimerais en trente et une analogie que
je trouve très parlante
l'analogie du corps humain considérons
regardons le corps humain comment est il
constitué d'organes de cellules de
formes différentes de fonctions
différentes de responsabilité différente
aucun organe et aucune cellule ne peut
vivre hors du corps humain car la
viabilité de chaque organe et de chaque
ellul dépend de la santé globale du
corps humain de même que la santé du
corps humain dépend de la viabilité de
chaque cellule et de chaque organe peu
importe leur taille peu importe leurs
responsabilités chaque cellule chaque
organe est indispensable au bon
fonctionnement de l'ensemble par
extension est ce qu'on pourrait
considérer que le bien-être de chaque
segment de la population le bien-être de
chaque individu de chaque famille peuple
dépend du bien-être de l'ensemble de
l'humanité est ce qu'on pourrait
considérer que la prospérité de chaque
individu dépend de la prospérité de
l'ensemble
mais alors si on part dans cette
direction comment est-ce qu'on définit
la prospérité qu'est ce que la
prospérité est ce que vous avez déjà
essayé de réfléchir à casquette et la
prospérité et je fais l'exercice de
chercher des films au nîmes à prospérité
les premiers mots qui sortent son
aisance fortune richesse en fait la
prospérité nous avons tendance à la
définir par des indicateurs économiques
matérialiste on jauge de la prospérité
parce qu'on les biens dont on a à notre
disposition
certaines sociétés ont atteint ce
qu'aujourd'hui on définit par la
prospérité mais alors est-ce que cette
prospérité nous a permis aujourd'hui
d'être heureux j'ai tendance à penser
qu'on vit aujourd'hui dans une société
de surconsommation surconsommation de
bien sûr consommation d'aliments
surconsommation de plaisir on pourrait
penser qu'on a atteint la prospérité
puisqu'on a atteint ce bien-être
matériel finalement qu'on cherche
mais sommes nous pour autant heureux et
surtout avons nous pour autant atteint
une prospérité matérielle universel est
ce que finalement cette boulimie
matérialiste dans laquelle nous vivons
ne cache pas plutôt une frustration plus
profonde des questions auxquelles nous
n'avons pas encore trouvé de réponse des
questions comme qui nous sommes
dans quel but nous existons comment nous
devrions nous pourrions vivre nos vies
et comment nous devrions agir les uns
avec les autres
alors ces questions je ne suis
certainement pas la seule à me poser
prendre en compte une dimension autre
que matériel je ne suis certainement pas
la seule à être dans cette dans cette
réflexion regardant quelques unes des
problématiques aujourd'hui qui sont au
coeur de l'action d'individus
d'associations de ng les droits de
l'homme la lutte contre les préjugés la
protection de l'environnement l'économie
solidaire
je vous laisse remplir les trous qui
reste ya encore tellement de sujets qui
montrent qu'aujourd'hui l'humanité est
en quête d'autre chose que d'une
prospérité matérielle et il est évident
que nous devons atteindre ces deux
prospérité matérielle et spirituelle qui
vont de pair pour pouvoir atteindre
l'unité pour pouvoir atteindre la paix
mondiale mais alors si ce changement est
inévitable si ce changement est possible
qui sont les protagonistes de ce
changement qui va permettre que ce
changement se réalisent réellement alors
dans le sein de l'association n'a réussi
à identifier trois protagonistes que
nous connaissons tous les individus la
communauté les institutions ce sont des
protagonistes qui font partie de notre
vie les individus ce sont nous mêmes on
fait partie d'une communauté les
institutions d'un on en fit plus ou
moins partis en tout cas certains plus
que d'autres mais si l'on regarde la
relation entre ces trois protagonistes
aujourd'hui finalement le dialogue est
rompu entre ces trois protagonistes
le dialogue est rompu parce qu'on a
l'impression que les intérêts des
individus ne sont pas prises en compte
par les institutions les institutions
attend peut-être plus des individus
alors comment on fait pour re connecter
ces trois protagonistes
est ce qu'il ne faut pas en fait une
vision nouvelle du rôle de chacun de ses
protagonistes et une vision nouvelle
aussi de l'interaction que peuvent avoir
ces trois protagonistes
alors pour étant considéré que
l'individu est le premier maillon de la
chaîne le maillon indispensable à ce
changement
premier maillon pourquoi et pourquoi
indispensable puisque sans l'individu
sans une action concrète
aucun changement ne peut aboutir donc
finalement c'est l'individu qui va faire
le passé l'individu qui va réussir à
mettre en pratique des théories des
principes des projets c'est l'individu
qu'il vit dans un voisinage qui vit dans
un quartier dans une ville dans un dans
un village c'est l'individu qui peut
prendre en main des projets et initier
des actions le concret donc est la
conséquence d'une action de l'individu
donc l'individu et ce premier maillon
indispensable
les individus nous comme je disais nous
sommes tous différents et cette
diversité est importante à maintenir
c'est ce qui fait la richesse de l'inde
de la richesse de la communauté
justement la communauté peut être
définie à la différence d'un simple
ensemble parole un cousin un ensemble
d'individus avec des intérêts des
fonctions des responsabilités
différentes mais qui travaillent tous
dans le même but avec la même vision et
enfin les institutions peut-on
considérer que les institutions déjà
sont composés des individus mais qu'en
plus elles ont pour mission d'aider la
communauté d'accompagner la communauté à
stimuler et à développer les actions
individuelles à permettre de libérer le
potentiel it et de chaque individu
le chemin ne voudrais vous proposer qu
est un schéma qui a quitté déjà mis en
oeuvre dans le cadre de cette
association est un schéma qui se base
sur un fonctionnement avec quelques mots
clés que ceux qui sont l'apprentissage
la coopération et la consultation
chaque individu va avoir une action
concrète dans un espace géographique
donnée cette action va forcément donner
lieu à un apprentissage
ces apprentissages sont alors mis en
commun ces apprentissages qui viennent
du quatre coins du monde
parce que ce sont les mêmes activités
avec les enfants avec les prés jeunes
qui ont lieu en afrique en asie en
europe et en amérique par tout ce sont
les mêmes activités avec la même vision
que l'unité est possible que la paix est
possible
mais ces activités vont
donner lieu à des apprentissages
différents ces apprentissages sont mis
en commun et de ses apprentissages les
institutions vont pouvoir tirer des
leçons qui seront la base de leurs
décisions
mais plutôt que de parler de décisions
j'aimerai parler de sujétion et de
propositions
les institutions vont pouvoir en se
basant sur l'apprentissage donc de la
base des individus proposé de proposer
et faire des suggestions d'actions de
principe de projets et ses suggestions
sont faites à la communauté puisque la
communauté va permettre à chaque
individu de libérer son potentiel de
libérer sa créativité et de se mettre en
mouvement pour aller vers un changement
et donc on est dans un cercle vertueux
qui ne s'arrête jamais puisque les
institutions se base toujours sur les
apprentissages individuel et collectif
alors ces apprentissages comme je disais
viennent des quatre coins du monde
elles viennent de moi elles viennent de
vous donc je vous passe le relais
aujourd'hui quel choix pouvez vous faire
quel choix pouvons nous faire tous
ensemble pour que la paix mondiale ne
soit plus juste une illusion une utopie
mais qu'elle devienne une réalité
peut-être pas pour nous mais pour les
générations futures
mais au moins que nous essayons nous
d'établir l'unité du genre humain
la prospérité matérielle et spirituelle
universel je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]